I'm going to talk about the implications
of an economic approach to ecosystems
and biodiversity for business I have
seen the course outline so I have an
idea of what the kind of material you've
covered up until now and I'm not going
to go over introductory material about
what is biodiversity what's happening to
it what are ecosystem services how does
that relate to biodiversity what is the
economic perspective on all of that how
do we value biodiversity and ecosystem
services I'm taking all that is given
and focusing just on what does this mean
for business and what can business do
about it
I have the panda bear up there and
that's the only time you'll see the
panda bear and that's simply because
I've just accepted a job and I'll be
moving to Sydney Australia which is a
dream come true for me and my wife and
they had nothing to do with this part of
tea but since I'm employed by them as of
two days ago
I thought I should put up the the logo
so what I'm going to talk about today
the first of the three lectures is why
should business care and then secondly
can we kind of unpack a little bit which
businesses should care more or less and
why in terms of which businesses which
sectors have the greatest impacts on
biodiversity and I put the plus or minus
there because those impacts are not
always negative business can have
positive impacts on biodiversity and
ecosystems as well as negative impacts
and of course business many of them also
depend on biodiversity and ecosystem
services and I'll go into that in a bit
more detail towards the end of the
lecture I'm going to present a case
study and a little bit more detail
showing some work that was done recently
while I was still at IUCN in my previous
job in partnership with a one of the
world's largest cement companies called
Holcim which is a Swiss based company
although the case study was actually in
the United Kingdom and hopefully we'll
have time to discuss all of this
firstly then why are companies
interested there are many different
reasons and I'm sure you could tell me
as well what those those reasons are but
broadly speaking I think we can talk
about internal reasons internal to a
business and external pressures of
various kinds
now internal built business drivers I've
included consumer preference because
businesses are very focused on meeting
the demands of their customers but also
we need to think about the awareness or
the concern of the managers of a
business themselves because they're part
of this story and they're reading the
the press and other media just as the
rest of us are so they know increasingly
what's going on they're concerned about
it they're also very focused on what
their customers want which may or may
not have something to do with the
environment and they're also concerned
with what their investors want
particularly publicly listed companies
whose shares are sold in the market they
need to pay close attention to what
shareholders are saying in terms of
external pressures there's general
public concern about the environment
increasingly stringent product standards
as well as regulatory requirements so
I'm distinguishing here between
voluntary standards and legal
requirements and more and more
governments are looking to business for
answers to the biodiversity crisis
looking a little bit more closely at
what's going on within business
management and as part of the Teebs
study about a year and two months ago we
had the great good fortune to have
McKinsey come to us and say could we do
a survey as a contribution to teeb and
use their contacts in the business world
about 1,500 senior executives from
around the world to try and understand
what our business attitudes towards what
our managers attitudes towards
biodiversity and ecosystems and we had
to spend a lot of time trying to
translate the the language of
biodiversity and ecosystems into
something that would be meaningful to
these executives hopefully we did that
so
part of the survey was defining our
terms and this is just one example from
the results suggesting that the the
leading reason that these executives
identified biodiversity as a possible
concern to their business was reputation
they want to ensure that they are seen
as good corporate citizens that they are
not seen as the bad guys now the
question is how important is that really
and what are they doing about it that's
another question but certainly
reputation was top of the list of the
reasons that the executives identified
for why they should care but the the
next two down are also interesting one
is the alignment with the company's
business goals mission or values and
there again I think we tend to forget
sometimes that people in business are us
often they're the same they're part of
society they want their companies to be
doing the right thing they want their
business to be contributing to their
their personal goals they want some
alignment or consistency between what
their business is doing and what they
they believe in and I think we shouldn't
discount that as a real driver of change
and thirdly not surprisingly responding
to regulatory requirements many
businesses see increasingly stringent
rules and regulations new laws coming on
the books related to biodiversity and
ecosystems in many different countries
and of course they have to respond to
that so I just single out those those
top three there many other drivers which
I've already mentioned looking a little
bit more closely at the findings from
that survey the question arises which of
the following risks related to
biodiversity if any are likely to become
significant risks to your business in
the next one to three years so looking
into the future where do these
executives see biodiversity becoming
more of an issue to their businesses and
interestingly 39% out of those 1,500
said well they didn't see biodiversity
as an issue at all they may be right I
hope they're wrong but I think also
interesting more than half did see that
by
he was likely to become more of a
concern particularly around improving
their operations to reduce impacts
changes to their product design or the
services that they're providing to
reduce impact so very much focused on
the impact side lack of crucial inputs
the hole dependence issue was really a
small share only 12 percent and that
came as a surprise to me it may reflect
the nature of the companies that are
responding to this survey turning to a
different survey this one carried out
again for teeb by PricewaterhouseCoopers
and they asked a similar set of
questions about a year earlier than
McKinsey and I've singled out this
particular chart one of many in their
report which looks at regional
differences in the level of concern
about biodiversity loss to again about
1,500 business leaders different
business leaders in this case maybe some
of the same people and it's striking to
me that Latin America and Africa are the
highest in terms of the awareness and
concern about biodiversity loss North
America
including of course the US was right
down there with Central and Eastern
Europe which is cee moving on to the
consumer side of things we have many
examples around the world in different
countries and in different sectors of
changes in consumer preference and the
fact that people want green goods and
services they want to buy products that
make them feel good that are healthy
that do not damage the environment and
we can see that in the growth of these
so-called sustainable segments of many
traditional markets forest products
fisheries products or food and other
agricultural products and many of those
are backed up by various and voluntary
standards as you can see from the the
logos and of course the business
response to that similarly on the
Investor side we've seen especially in
the US but also to some extent in Europe
and other regions more and more interest
on the part of both retail and
institutional investors in so-called
ethical investment or socially
responsible investment or green
investment for people's pension funds or
their their bank accounts or that even
their mortgages and here again I think
we're starting to see business
responding to this and to some extent
factoring biodiversity and ecosystems
into these the the factors that they
consider for the most part I'd have to
say that socially responsible investment
doesn't pay a lot of attention to
biodiversity and ecosystems where they
talk about the environment it's usually
climate change but I think there's an
openness there to consider biodiversity
and ecosystems as a factor in investment
management this is really in pollen
serie more than mine so he would be able
to expand on that and then looking
outside its some other I guess these are
related factors this is from a survey of
5,000 consumers in France Germany the
United Kingdom the US and Brazil that
was carried out last year 2010 and this
is done every year it's one of these few
surveys that actually shows some time
trend and it's interesting that more and
more consumers have heard the term
biodiversity they have an idea what that
might mean and in this particular survey
they asked people to define biodiversity
and some people came back and said oh
yes we have a we have a diversity
poverty policy in our business we employ
people from all backgrounds so not
everybody gets it right but 60% of
consumers in Europe and the US had heard
of biodiversity and defined it correctly
they understood what it was that it was
associated with ecosystems and the
services that they you get from nature
and many of the respondents also
asserted and claimed that they would
change their their purchasing practices
as a result of their understanding of
whether a company was behaving in a
responsible manner whether they do in
fact that's another question one would
need some follow-up on
interestingly many consumers want
independent verification so they're not
satisfied with self certification by
companies they want third-party
independent validation of the claims
that companies are making one thing I
haven't put on this slide but from the
same survey is there's much higher
levels of awareness and understanding of
what biodiversity is in Brazil than in
some of these developed economies and
that's related to the finding of the
McKenzie and the sorry the
PricewaterhouseCoopers survey I think
there's just been generally more
discussion in those countries of what is
biodiversity what's happening to it and
why does that matter
product standards I talked a little bit
about the increasing kasoori
biodiversity and ecosystem services in a
range of different voluntary product
standards these are just a couple of
examples from agriculture in the UK and
from the carbon market the voluntary
carbon market here in the US
Conservation International and others
have set up these CC B standards that
combine not just quality carbon but also
biodiversity performance and companies
now respond to that in the in their
product offerings and try to produce
goods and services that that can
demonstrate their environmental
credentials I mentioned regulatory
reform more and more governments are
looking not just at the standard command
and control approaches to environmental
management but also trying to change the
incentives to make it more costly to do
the wrong thing more profitable to do
the right thing and I'll be talking a
little bit more about that in future
lectures and lastly I mentioned that
more and more governments are not just
looking to refine the sticks that they
use and the incentives that they offer
but also they want to have a
collaboration with industry around
biodiversity and so you see this for
example in the decision of the
Convention on Biological Diversity this
international treaty
reaching out to the business community
and that's new the treaty has been in
place since 1992 but it's only within
the last five or six years that they've
started to pay attention to the business
world to think about how do we engage
the private sector in these goals of
biodiversity conservation and that's
true also at a national level so having
looked a little bit at some of the
factors that are driving business
interest in biodiversity and ecosystem
services we need to start unpacking a
little bit and understanding which
sectors which companies have the
greatest impacts positive or negative or
the greatest dependence and apologies
for those who may have looked at the
slides that I sent yesterday and I
modified them slightly I guess that's my
prerogative on the basis of a report
that just came out two or three days ago
so I thought it was interesting to have
a quick look what are they saying about
the linkages how do we understand the
relationship between different
businesses and biodiversity and I like
this particular figure because it shows
that it tries to to boil down a lot of
different linkages and relationships all
together starting at the bottom with the
organization which could be the company
could be a public agency which both
benefits from ecosystem services both
the stocks and the flows and it's
important to recognize those two aspects
and also creates pressures impacts on
those ecosystems that affect those those
flows the figure also reflects the fact
that pressures on ecosystems come from
many different sources including other
stakeholders and business often asks
well what am I responsible for versus
what other changes may be taking place
including natural causes that may be
going on behind the scenes affecting the
quality or quantity of ecosystem
services other stakeholders benefit from
those same ecosystems and services that
the business is benefitting from you put
all of that together the organization or
the business has to come up with some
responses taking account of interests of
other stakeholders their benefits their
pressures natural cause
and so on so I found it it's a it's a
slightly complicated figure but a useful
one for showing the different
relationships between an organization
and ecosystems now that's all very well
to have that kind of theoretical
understanding when you look at practice
most companies don't bother to be quite
honest these are the top 100 companies
in the world by market value and their
reporting and the extent to which their
annual reports or their sustainability
reports pay attention to biodiversity
and ecosystem issues and you can see on
the left in the annual reports that
something like two percent two companies
out of a hundred identify biodiversity
as a key strategic issue so it's still
pretty low on the radar screen and and
less than a quarter all together whereas
actually less than a fifth of those top
100 companies altogether mentioned
biodiversity at all when you look at
sustainability reports the same
companies again even their biodiversity
is relatively low something like just
over 40% make no mention of biodiversity
and their sustainability reports they're
talking about community energy
efficiency water use but not
biodiversity or ecosystem services and
one of the reasons for that is they
don't know what to report so in the case
of climate change or energy we have a
simple indicator people can talk about
efficiency they can talk about co2
equivalence of their emissions or the
offsets that they may have delivered in
the case of biodiversity and ecosystems
that the conservation community is still
grappling with how do we measure this
what do we want businesses or anyone
else to deliver and so this is just a
selection of some of the indicators that
were pulled together as scientific input
to the 10th Conference of the parties of
the Convention on Biological Diversity
last year to say this is the state of
the world this is the state of
biodiversity today and there are lots of
interesting indicators here but most of
them are
suitable for business if you have a look
what business needs are indicators they
can use at the level of a facility a
site or product or that they can
aggregate across many different product
lines many facilities at so they have a
sort of group wide indicator they need
to be able to measure not only their
their processes their production
processes but also their their
performance in sort of hard terms and
they need them both for internal and
external reporting again most of the
indicators that the conservation
community has been looking at for the
last 30 40 years don't lend themselves
to business reporting and so that's
that's a bit of a challenge
nevertheless some companies are trying
to get around this and here's an example
of a brewery SABMiller major operations
in sub-saharan Africa and other regions
they look at water in particular you'd
expect that from a beer producer and
they have targets that they've set that
they can measure year-on-year they
compare across their different regional
operations how well they're doing on the
efficiency of water use and they look at
both where they're getting water from
and what quality of water they're
putting back into the ecosystems so
that's one example works fine for a
brewery when you get into other sectors
it's more complicated this is from Rico
Reiko I don't know how you say it's a
Japanese company that makes
multifunctional digital copiers what we
might call Xerox machines although
that's a trademarked term so there this
was a report done for them to try and
understand what are the links between
the electric electronic copier business
and biodiversity and they it's a very
complicated chart unfortunately and I'm
not going to try and take you through it
but they had to look at the whole
production process looking upstream at
raw material supply looking downstream
at the use of the Machine and the
eventual disposal of the machine and try
to identify all the pollutants and all
the resources that went into this
production process to
she's out the links with biodiversity
you can imagine trying to turn this kind
of chart into a simple report is not
going to be straightforward and every
sector is going to have a different
chart like that so it's not easy having
said that there are many people trying
to simplify reporting requirements and
expectations for business and just a few
of them mentioned here you have the
Global Reporting Initiative GRI which
has done a lot of work on voluntary
reporting for companies and other
organizations on social and
environmental issues and they recently
came out with some work on ecosystem
services which I'll talk about in a
moment
you have the Carbon Disclosure Project
it's purely voluntary but driven by the
investment community and asking asking
their investees
to report on their carbon footprint in
their their actions visa vie climate
change based on that CDP you also have
the water footprint disclosure project
and the forest footprint disclosure
project and some people have talked
about a natural capital footprint
disclosure project there lots of these
these schemes coming up to try and help
businesses identify appropriate
indicators to assess their environmental
performance some of that work which is
mostly multi-stakeholder initiatives
purely voluntary is being now taken up
by more formal regulatory bodies so in
the UK the Institute of Chartered
Accountants of England and Wales got
together with the Environment Agency
Government Department to issue
guidelines on reporting on environmental
issues and these are not quite hard law
they're like soft law but in the United
States then you have the Securities and
Exchange Commission again coming out
with even more mandatory requirements on
how to deal with climate liabilities and
assets so based on that kind of
experience
you can see improvements in reporting
happening in the voluntary sector and
then gradually moving into the
regulatory environment and we can expect
this to happen probably with
biodiversity and ecosystem services
notwithstanding the challenge of what
indicators to use so I mentioned this
report that came out a few days ago
they're looking at these ecosystem
services in particular trying to come up
with indicators you can see it's still a
work in progress I particularly like for
genetic resources the percent of DNA
diversity I don't know anybody who has a
database on this or how they're going to
to get a handle on it but it's nice that
they're they're starting to think about
what that might mean now obviously in
economics we want to get away from
physical indicators or qualitative
indicators and we'd like to somehow find
a way to integrate information about
biodiversity and ecosystem services with
financial information about company
performance so that we're not just
always looking oh there's the real
annual report oh and then there's this
kind of fuzzy warm sustainability report
that the financial director never looks
at you want one one report on corporate
performance where these environmental
factors impacts and dependents are
reflected in financial terms and you've
already heard all about the valuation
methods fortunately I don't need to go
into this because they're complicated
and a bit tedious great fun to do if you
ever have the opportunity so I encourage
you but you know all about the different
valuation methods what's interesting to
me is that businesses started to notice
also so for a long time these valuation
methods were used only in the public
sector or by academics you know you can
go get a degree in environmental
economics they'll teach you how to do a
contingent valuation or travel cost
model and then you can get a job at the
US EPA or the equivalent in other
countries but until recently business
wasn't interested they didn't even know
so a couple of years ago
when again when I was working at IUCN we
got together with something called the
World Business Council for sustainable
development that's this logo here which
is a 200 member Network of the biggest
companies in the world and they found
some volunteers among their members and
you have the logos there who are willing
to see whether valuation of ecosystem
services could be adapted to their
business needs could we use those
complicated methods in a business
context to do a variety of things and as
it says there to try and reduce costs
maybe operating costs or taxes and other
fees try and generate additional revenue
or to assess liability and compensation
requirements and I'll come back to an
application in a moment okay taking
those valuation methods and applying it
to business there have been some very
preliminary attempts and I think this is
a slide that you may have seen during
the shopping week
is that right Pavan this was a study
carried out by true cost
it's a uk-based consulting firm on
behalf of the United Nations principles
for responsible investment focused on
the financial services industry and what
they did is they essentially took a
giant input-output data base of that
links levels of output in different
sectors to levels of resource use or
pollution in those same sectors the data
I think originally comes from the US EPA
mainly but they've supplemented that
with some other countries as well and
what they then did is simply say okay
given the structure of the economy and
the levels of output in these different
sectors what can we say about the use of
resources and the pollution from those
companies and they looked at 3,000
companies listed on stock exchanges
around the world and then let's put
prices on them and they used those
valuation techniques with a lot of
heroic benefits transfer I guess you've
heard about benefits transfer
to try and assign values to those
pollution pollutants and use of
resources and this is what they came up
with and I guess Pavan may have gone
into this a little bit but essentially
because the data that's available is
very heavily weighted towards greenhouse
gases the green portions of the bars are
basically the bulk of the problem in
their analysis and those are greenhouse
gas emissions as the value of greenhouse
gas emissions using I believe the social
accounting price for carbon not the
market price I assume you've discussed
the difference between the social price
of carbon and the market price of carbon
yes thank you food producers as you
would expect come out heavily weighted
by water use no surprise there what
strikes me however is that again
biodiversity Nemo's other ecosystem
services related to biodiversity don't
figure here and that's just a it's a
reflection of the data that is available
if you look at US EPA's input-output
data they don't tell you about use of
ecosystem services or impacts on
biodiversity so and even if they did we
don't have prices for most of those
ecosystem services so it would be very
difficult to construct a table like this
that's an area that still needs work
here's an example not at a global level
but at a country level and a sector this
is forestry in China Pavan you didn't
use this one I don't think no ok so here
they the analysts again true cost and
this was done on behalf of teeb tried to
look at a broader range of ecosystem
services related to deforestation and to
link that to logging and the use of
timber in the Chinese economy during the
60s 70s and 80s and 90s and they came up
with an estimate of the loss of
ecosystem services resulting from
deforestation that could be attributed
to the production
Timber for the materials in construction
industry in China and then they said
okay let's add up those environmental
costs and compare it to the market price
and you can see in the chart on the left
that the environmental costs are greater
than the the market price of timber in
Beijing in 1998 which is interesting
partly because the market price in 1998
did not reflect any of those ecosystem
impacts so that market price the the
green bar and that was the costs of you
know accessing the land extracting the
timber producing it shipping it to
Beijing in some semi-finished form in
cubic meters dollars per cubic meter it
did not include those environmental
impacts and if those environmental
impacts had been reflected in the market
price of timber you would imagine a lot
of changes in the the use of timber in
China now what's interesting also is
that around about the same time there
were some environmental disasters in
China including major flooding which was
attributed to deforestation and thus to
logging and there was a logging ban
imposed shortly after 1998 I think in
1998 as a result of which - you could
say that the logging ban took account of
these environmental impacts and
corrected the market failure but you
could also point to the fact that the
consumption of timber in China did not
go down the construction boom continued
is just they found their timber
somewhere else they imported it so those
environmental costs have been shifted
from Chinese forests to other forests
and you'd have to look at well where is
the construction industry in China now
getting its timber from and are those
countries managing their forests in an
appropriate way do they have policies
that reflect these environmental impacts
unfortunately in many cases they don't
so I talked a lot about business impacts
on the environment and mostly I realized
I've talked about negative impacts I'll
get back to positive later on but I
think it's another area that people tend
not to talk about enough in my view is
the dependence of business on
biodiversity and ecosystem services and
this is one very obvious example in
agriculture is the role of wild insects
and other animals in pollination and the
value that that delivers to agriculture
now we know that the value of food
includes the value of pollination
because without the pollination there's
no food but typically in many parts of
the world farmers do not pay for
pollination services interestingly in
the u.s. for some crops they do for
almonds in California for blueberries in
this case in Michigan farmers will pay
for pollination services and we can see
from that what's the value to in terms
of the value-added of those pollinators
to agriculture in the u.s. it's very
often domesticated bees that are rented
for the purpose people will rent the
hive the bees will come and pollinate
the crop the farmer then pays the owner
of the beehives who moves on to the next
farm the problem is you probably know is
that in North America and some other
continents we have a problem with
domesticated bees namely they're dying
right so this colony collapse disorder
then has generated more interest in how
do we maintain populations of wild bees
and wild pollination services and the
case study that we we have in teeb is
from Syngenta which is an agribusiness
company they produce chemicals and seeds
for farming and they realize that the
health of their business depends on the
health of farmers and the health of
farmers depends on the health of
pollinators and so they've invested with
the US Department of Agriculture and
others in something called I think
operation Paul
which is an attempt to try and restore
habitat for wild pollinators as a kind
of backstop if we don't find a solution
to the whatever's affecting domesticated
bees will at least have the wild
pollinators to maintain production to
some extent okay
I've talked a lot probably too much and
I should have said at the outset that
I'm very happy for anyone to interrupt
me at any time
and say we know all that or to ask a
question or to disagree or whatever you
wish to do yes I would agree with that
my experience of working with some some
big companies is that they're slightly
schizophrenic just like any big
institution like the US government
you'll find people that hold very
different points of view within the same
organization so the people working on
health safety and environment or
sustainability they will have a very
different set of priorities but they
don't generally run the show they don't
have as much influence say as the
financial directors and other chief
other executives I think the the Global
Reporting Initiative is on the right
track this is a very simplistic approach
what they've got here but this is an
attempt is it I don't know if this is
the answer to your question but they're
trying to boil it down to a few products
or resources that would be intelligible
to most companies the ones listed on the
left there and then a few simple ways to
measure those now I'm not convinced that
all of these are going to work so for
example look at fibre which would
include most forestry pulp and paper and
they want they're interested in the
volume or weight or the area planted
well that's not gonna get us very close
to biodiversity is it I mean so I think
there's still a lot of work to be done
and I'll talk a little bit next week
about what's called a habitat hectares
approach which is kind of area with a
quality adjustment
you sound like you're from Australia
okay well that's where it comes from as
you probably know the habitat Hector's
approach and they're people who've
developed similar metrics here in the
u.s. related to wetland mitigation
banking and conscious species
conservation banking schemes it's a
similar approach but there's still a
long way to go there's a lot in that
question because I think what consumers
need is different from what the business
needs business can probably afford to
dive deeper get more technical more
detailed consumer just want something
they can quickly eyeball in the
supermarket or without having to think
too much about what's inside that
they're more concerned perhaps about
credibility is it independently verified
as opposed to self certified I think
it's instructive to look at the example
of climate change and what happened
there it's simpler because you can take
16 greenhouse gases or however many they
took and boil them down to co2
equivalent it's fairly straightforward
the chemistry is not complicated
biodiversity is never gonna be that
simple so you're never gonna be able to
boil it down to one indicator I don't
think you probably need to look at
sector specific sets of indicators but
what is instructive about the the
greenhouse gas example is at one stage
probably in the mid 90s the World
Resources Institute based in Washington
an NGO got together with the World
Business Council for sustainable
development I mentioned them before a
big business umbrella group and came up
with a protocol for measuring greenhouse
gases in business and I think you need
something like that that has the
scientific credibility from the
biodiversity crowd but also the business
credibility of an organization like WBC
SD to say this is the protocol this is
how you measure it and this is best
practice it doesn't have to be
government that does that but there has
to be buy-in from both the scientific
side and the business side yeah I think
that's that well as I said if you don't
do that you end up with these kind of
indicators you know I've been working in
IUCN for nine years with a lot of
ecologists and constant
and biologists and and land use
management specialists and they come up
with great indicators but they're at a
different level they're good for sort of
landscape level national level
assessments and and planning but they're
not adapted to the needs of a big
business or a little business okay I
will move on in that case I have a
little case study about valuing
ecosystem impacts positive and actually
in this case part mostly positive some
negative and this was a case study
carried out as a contribution to that
wbcs d guide I mentioned on how to use
valuation in in a corporate context they
had what we call I'll go back to that
briefly
they had Road testers so those logos on
the bottom are the companies that
volunteered to try out these valuation
techniques that you learned about the
last few weeks and apply them to their
situation so you've got many different
sectors you've got agribusiness
environmental services for a pulp and
paper mining pulp and paper again cement
to cement companies electronics Escom is
a big southern African power producer
they have mainly Coal Fired power plants
some hydro Eni is an oil and gas
producer EDP I forget you've got
chemicals ASCO Nobel pharmaceuticals and
so on so you've got a range of different
sectors they all agreed to say alright
we'll partner up with some valuation
specialists people who know how to value
ecosystem services and see if we can
come up with something interesting and
IUCN was part of that and one of the
case studies that we did as part of this
project was with wholesome big Cement
Company they have in the United Kingdom
in Yorkshire some quarries from which
they extract sand and gravel big
component in concrete as you know and
they were interested in
how to maximize the environmental
benefit of the restoration and Rehab
that they are required by law to do as a
condition for getting a permit to dig
sand and gravel and so they weren't
wondered whether valuation could help
them in that planning process of
figuring out what is the best
restoration and rehabilitation option
for them and they would claim at Holcim
that they look at biodiversity
throughout the project cycle and I think
it's it's fair to say that extractive
companies big extractive companies do
have more experience thinking about
biodiversity and ecosystems because they
have a big footprint on the landscape
right there digging giant holes in the
ground and they're under a lot of
pressure from stakeholders NGOs and
others who are saying hey you're digging
giant holes in the ground what are you
doing about that and governments have
responded and imposed various
requirements to restore or rehabilitate
queries and and mining sites so they do
have a bit more experience say than an
electronics manufacturing company and
wholesome like some others tries to
think about biodiversity at different
stages in the project cycle including
before the the decision about whether to
go ahead or not with with the project
I'm not always clear whether how much
weight is given to biodiversity and that
go/no-go decision but they would say
it's certainly a factor and of course
most queries do have a limited life and
so they think about well what are they
going to do to shut down the project and
leave the environment in a decent
condition particularly when they're
working in highly regulated environments
like the UK the starting point for
wholesome like many companies in this
process was a previous tool developed by
the World Resources Institute scald the
corporate ecosystem service review tool
or ESR and it's a kind of qualitative
first screening that companies can do to
understand what is their relationship to
biodiversity and ecosystem services what
are the priority impacts or do
tendencies what are they doing about it
what could they do more could they do
but then we wanted to go beyond that
qualitative assessment and look in this
case at the economic values at stake and
the decision context here was that the
company wanted to expand their query
they wanted to take more sand and gravel
out from this area in in Yorkshire and
they needed a permit to do that and
already under the law in the UK they
have to rehabilitate the the quarry at
the end of its life and they were
proposing a mixture of wetlands and
recreational waterways they were going
to basically create reed beds which are
good habitat for birds and they were
also proposing to create a lake for
boating and fishing and angling and so
on and they were curious to know what
was the best option particularly because
there were two environmental NGOs in the
region who disagreed with each other
one NGO was really interested in birds
and said obviously the best thing you
could do is create reedbeds
bird habitat and there was another NGO
that said no we think the recreations
more important so you should perhaps
forget about the birds and put more
emphasis on on on the recreational
opportunities and the company is caught
between those and the local government
and other people to try and figure out
well what kind of information can
economic valuation bring that would help
in this this decision-making I'm not
sure how meaningful this is but it will
give you a sense of the the area it's a
very Frell ative lee small area in
floodplain the land that they were
looking at where they wanted to extend
their operations was currently pretty
low value agricultural land a lot of it
used for livestock because it's
seasonally flooded pasture not
particularly profitable agricultural
land but not zero and this is a picture
of what they were proposing to do
in terms of restoration you can see
there's an area where they were
suggesting to put a reed bed in another
area to put a lake and so what we tried
to do in this case was apply
cost-benefit analysis as the framework
and some of these valuation techniques
with a heavy reliance on benefits
transfer because we didn't have the time
or resources to go out and collect new
data
fortunately the UK has been studied
quite intensively by environmental
economists and so there there is a rich
database that we can use even from the
region we could find values from other
studies in North Yorkshire which we
could transfer not very far away to this
site mm-hmm and we needed a reference
scenario as well as a project scenario
the reference scenario was no extension
permit denied just stick with the status
quo of intensive agriculture and some
flood control that was already in place
versus what the company wanted to do
which was take the sand and gravel and
then restore it afterwards and we tried
to look at a range of different
ecosystem services biodiversity by which
we meant bird habitat basically and the
existence values of the birds that would
be created by restoring this wetland
recreational values flood control and
carbon storage we thought we'd throw
that in as well just to see is there
carbon a climate mitigation benefit from
this restoration activity and as you
will know we needed to look at non
market values so taken an economic
approach as opposed to just the
financial flows just as an aside here
the company was very reluctant to tell
us how much money they were going to
make from the querying operations they
didn't really want that to be part of
the discussion but if you do include
those values it swamps the whole story
because it's a very profitable business
basically so for biodiversity we looked
at habitat mainly for birds we looked at
previous willingness to pay surveys that
have been conducted not too far away in
Northumberland I'm not sure is that a
neighboring County of Yorkshire I should
know but I don't and I think that was a
contingent valuation survey that was
done estimating the value of wetlands on
farmland or the wetland creation on
farmland at 53 UK pounds per household
per year for five years it's a very
precise estimate there that we were able
to to adapt we had to adjust for the
population the distance of the
population from the wetlands how many
households they are how big is the area
that was going to be created so you make
various adjustments as you know when you
you conduct a benefits transfer exercise
similarly for recreation we had at
previous estimates of willingness to pay
of individuals for marginal boating
opportunities in the area valued at just
under five pounds per resident per year
we had to make some assumptions about
how many boaters would be able to use
this new lake if it were created and how
that would change over time flood
control we have some estimates I think
from the UK government of the the per
hectare value of maintaining wetlands
for flood protection 892 pounds per
hectare per year fairly substantial
value and surprisingly carbon storage
came in very low you don't get a lot of
climate mitigation benefit from wetlands
in that region that's not the case in
the tropics where you can get some very
high values depends on the vegetation
and what's happening in the soils we
also looked at the cost side of the
equation what are the restoration costs
but also one of the aftercare costs to
manage these areas over a 50-year
contract and what kind of funding would
need to be put in place to manage those
those wetlands for 50 years and
importantly we looked at the opportunity
costs of forgone agricultural output and
as you'll see very different mixed
estimates of costs and benefits on the
left side you've got the benefits and to
my surprise the habitat creation was the
biggest single estimate again that is
the amount the willings to pay of
households in that part of the united
kingdom for the creation of wetlands as
habitat mainly for birds a very precise
definition of the benefit in question
recreation significant but much less
than the biodiversity the existence
values of those habitats flood storage
measurable carbon sequestration
virtually invisible on the cost side
again as you would expect I think the
opportunity cost was the biggest item so
the loss of agricultural output from
converting from floodplain agriculture
to to wetland conservation the
restoration costs and the management
cost of those protected areas not huge
if you put that together benefits
outweigh costs
I suppose the the main point here that
was of interest to the company is to be
able to say that they are delivering
value that it's measurable economic
value it's greater than the costs that
they are incurring themselves or that
they are imposing on the agricultural
producers and that this although they
can't cash in they can't turn that value
into cash flow for the company there
nevertheless making a positive
contribution to the economy of the area
in terms of these environmental benefits
so just some some brief thoughts on what
they concluded from this the values of
wetland restoration and creation are
significant the costs are relatively
small as you'd expect the net benefits
our greatest where the opportunity costs
are lower and they were most excited
about the possibility to integrate this
valuation approach into their existing
procedures most like most companies they
have very elaborate procedures for
environmental and social impact
assessment yes
ESI a which typically do not include any
kind of economic valuation so they were
looking at this as
a test case a pilot to use valuation
build that into their environmental and
social impact assessment to try and
deliver better decisions on how to use
restoration resources okay what I've
tried to do and I realize we've still
got some time ahead of us briefly wanted
to look at what's the business case why
should business care about biodiversity
ecosystems what are the drivers of those
of changes in interests how do we
understand the linkages positive and
negative and dependence between business
and biodiversity and I looked at a case
study example what I'm proposing to do
next week is to look at the next
sequence of chapters in the the teeb for
business report looking at what kind of
things can business do to avoid or
mitigate biodiversity risks what are the
new business opportunities in
biodiversity and ecosystems and then
lastly how do we get what can we expect
business to do on their own on a
voluntary basis and what requires
government action to try and tighten up
the the rules that they they work on how
do we change the incentives this is a
slide you've all seen before I took the
liberty of adding some additional logos
these are the different organizations
that contributed to the teep for
Business Report I will stop there
briefly and I realize we've got some
time still about 10 10 15 minutes yeah